(dramatic intro music)
- Oh man, well welcome to the show,
but what happened?
- Well, do you want the real story
or do you want the cool story?
- I want the cool story,
like you saved a baby from a shark.
- I did, I did.
- Yeah.
- So, here's the cool story.
We were out camping
with my kids and my wife
and a bear attacked us.
(laughing)
And I didn't know I had it in me.
I roundhouse kicked the bear
and then he like paused.
(laughing)
I didn't physically hurt the bear,
but I think emotionally I hurt the bear.
It started crying,
(laughing)
and I was, I started crying,
cuz I cry and we were
like, we talked it out
and everything was okay.
So, I just, I learned
not to kick bears, yeah.
- I love this story you've worked on.
I love that.
Now that's a, I had to,
I hurt my foot once.
Mine was also not a cool story
and I had to make one up.
I just tripped over a pedal board on stage
and I had to wear it though,
like while performing, like on doing shows
and it's like annoying.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And it's sweaty.
- It's sweaty.
I can't drive and my wife hates me for it.
It's 'cause I can't
- Oh.
- get the kids places.
It's all on her now.
- Oh, that's kinda nice though.
You're like, "Oh, the boot."
- Don't tell her that.
- Yeah, I would do that too.
Everybody loves you guys on the show.
We love the show,
but I also hear that you're musical,
which I did not know.
(audience clapping)
Did you also like DJ? Like EDM?
Like DJ, is that what? Is that real?
- I like that you came to me first
instead of the real musician.
- No, cuz I just love like how random,
I didn't know that.
- Yeah, well I wanted to.
I was really into it.
I was pretty good at it.
Beat matching like records and stuff.
- Yeah.
- And I love that music.
Good house music from the late 2000's.
- Yeah.
- Oh, and I love the club scene,
but I never quite made it
to where I was really
doing it as a real thing.
- But you love it.
- Now I'm a dad.
- It's like your passion.
(all laughing)
- Yeah.
- And I'm a mom.
- I do a talk show.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I get that.
No, I love it though.
You've been in several bands, right?
- Yeah, I've been playing
music since I was little.
Grew up in church,
started playing drums in church
when I was like 9, 10 years old.
- Yeah.
Something like that.
- And then, yeah, I've been in bands
since I can remember.
- Do you still play, like all the time?
- Yeah, I do.
I'm gonna be putting some
music out here pretty soon.
Look, I don't have,
- I hear things.
- your voice.
I'm not as good as you.
- Are you going Country?
- I'm going Country.
- I'm very excited.
- He's great.
- Yeah.
- That's how I saved, that's why,
'cause I love country music.
- Oh, good.
- I've always wanted to
make a country record.
So, I heard that that's what you're doing.
- Yes.
- So, I was very excited.
- Thank you, yeah.
- That's so cool.
- Yeah, thanks.
- Do you hang out in Nashville ever?
Are you ever in that scene or anything?
- Yeah, I was just there
- You're awesome.
- for like a couple
months this year actually,
- Yeah.
- doing some writing
and kind of just meeting the town
and getting to know everybody
and it's such a cool community there.
- So cool.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
Do you remember like, I
dunno, the first time,
the first concerts you ever went to?
- I do, yeah. (laughing)
- What was yours?
- I went to a Bon Jovi concert
with some friends.
- Yes.
- I was really young.
Yeah, yeah.
(audience clapping)
- That's a cool first concert.
- It was, it was amazing.
I was a little over excited.
I thought for,
I had a button up shirt over my T-shirt
and I didn't know how
to behave at a concert,
so I just like threw my
button up shirt on the stage.
I was like, "Yeah!"
(laughing)
Yeah?
- Yeah, right?
No, okay.
- You threw your clothes on the stage?
- Well it's just my button up,
not all of them.
- I know.
- I did-
- I was like,
"That's like how a woman
responds at a rock show."
- I know, I know.
I was confused.
(all laughing)
It was Bon Jovi.
(Kelly laughing)
I so loved him.
- I know.
- It's hard not to.
What about you? What
was your first concert?
- So, I grew up really Christian.
Wasn't really allowed to listen
to secular music.
(Kelly sharply inhaling)
- I wasn't either,
- Yeah?
- funny enough.
- Oh, okay.
There we go.
- Yes, Yeah.
- You remember Carmen?
- Did I go to the concert
- Do you remember Carmen?
in Dallas Texas? Yes.
- Absolutely.
- Yeah.
- It was like a,
it was like a love offering show.
You never had to buy a ticket.
You just, they like
passed a bucket around,
like it was church.
- Yeah, like the offering
plate kind of thing.
- Yeah, exactly.
So Carmen
- Yes.
- would've been my first concert.
- Oh my gosh.
- Yeah.
- I don't know if that was my first,
but it was one of my first.
And it literally was
where all the church kids went,
like, to go to a concert.
- Oh, yeah.
And you felt like you were cool.
- Yeah, Carmen was amazing.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- He had people like dressed
up like the devil on stage.
- Those days we were the devil, yeah.
- And Jesus would fight the devil.
- Yeah.
- Crazy.
- There was storytelling.
- Amazing.
- It was like an adventure.
- Yeah.
- Jovi's nothing.
Bon Jovi is nothing.
- It's so funny. I was-
- Bon, Bon who?
- Bon Jovi who?
(all laughing)
We were at Carmen.
- Yeah.
- I just love us like reading about,
you know, it's like, "Oh, my god.
You weren't allowed to
listen to secular either."
- Yeah.
- And now you're making a secular record
and like that's my whole career.
- Oh, I didn't even think about that.
- Our parents, our parents
must be so disappointed.
- Sorry, mom.
(all laughing)
- God invented love.
This is what we discuss.
Anyway, so we saw that your wife
recently posted these photos.
So, I wanna post.
So, I am upset.
First of all,
I don't know where this is,
but I have a ranch in Montana
and I also just recently,
for my birthday,
bought myself an Airstream.
So, I feel like
we should be friends,
- Oh, amazing.
me and your wife.
- Yeah.
Is this in Montana? Where is this?
- That is the Teton
Mountains in the background.
- Oh, okay, okay.
Oh, I should have recognized
- So that's the Idaho side
- that in Wyoming.
of the Teton Mountains.
At our buddy's house.
- Yeah.
- It's beautiful there.
- Oh, my god.
We were doing like a COVID bubble season
where my wife was,
it was like either come the whole time,
or don't come at all.
- Yeah.
- So she came and was like,
"Why don't we live here?"
- God, exactly.
- And so,
we got into it
- exactly.
- and just didn't wanna leave.
So, we bought a place there, yeah.
- It is very hard to leave.
- Yeah.
- I hear that you like
road trips as well, right?
- I do, I love road trips,
but my best road trips were
with my family as a kid.
We were, I was like 8
and one of our road trips
was to come out from Arkansas,
drive all the way out to LA and back.
And my dad had like a real plan.
Like, he had like the
forms and the, you know,
the charts and all that stuff.
And my mom was like, "You
know, we're not gonna do that.
Let's just drive off the road."
So, she like wanted to drive off the road
in the middle of the desert
and we'd end up on reservations
and places we would've never gone before.
- Yeah.
- It was a really exciting trip, yeah.
- Are you from Arkansas?
- I'm from Arkansas, yeah.
- Oh my gosh.
My favorite place I've ever camped
and like gone backpacking is Devil's Den.
- No way, really?
- Yeah.
I love Arkansas. It's beautiful.
- Most people are like,
"I don't think I've ever been there."
(laughing)
- You know, it's so funny.
Other than tour,
the only thing I've ever done there is,
yeah, is gone camping.
- Yeah?
- It's so beautiful.
- It's beautiful.
- Yeah.
- It's a beautiful state.
Yeah, yeah.
- Beautiful state.
I don't think people know that.
I didn't know that and then
my friend took me there
and I was like, "Whoo, this is a secret."
- Yeah.
- I was like,
- Yeah, really.
- "No one told me about this."
- A very big secret.
No one's coming, yeah.
- I know. It's awesome though.
It's really pretty.
(audience cheering and clapping)
- So for those that have
been living under a rock,
cuz everyone has seen Yellowstone,
if they haven't, what
is Yellowstone about?
- Yeah, I mean I have a quick
way to sort of describe it.
It's sort of like "Godfather."
The family's sort of like "The Godfather."
- Ah.
- There's also some Greek tragedy.
You mix that with Big Sky Country
and that's kind of the show.
- Yeah.
- Oh my God.
That's actually a really good way
to describe the show.
- The scene, "Cool, how's that?"
- Your character, Jamie,
is so intense.
Like, I often just find myself like this,
just watching your character,
cuz it's just,
I know you're actors and you, you know,
perform and then you go home.
Like I do like at a show or something,
or you do at a show.
But it just seems like,
is that hard not to
carry that weight home,
cuz your character is
maybe the hardest, I think,
on the show.
- Yeah, I can't compare,
cuz I don't know what
they're all going through,
but I know it's been a trip,
but I had prided myself-
- As a viewer I feel sorry for you.
- Oh, do you? Yeah, well-
- Yeah.
- Even when you're kind of a jerk,
I just feel sorry for you.
- I'll take it, I'll take it.
- Yeah.
- I need it for the healing.
(laughing)
It's tough, you know, like
I used to pride myself
on letting it go before I went home.
But this one, by season 2 or 3,
my wife was like, "You are different.
What's happening?"
- Yeah.
- And so I was carrying him home
and basically now he has the floor
and Wes is kind of off in the back
waiting for his moment again.
- Dude, yeah. It's an intense role.
And even like you'd said, "The Godfather,"
even the dynamic of family in it
is really hardcore.
- Yeah.
- Very tough.
Scenes with Beth are tough, you know,
and she, it's a hard thing to get through,
but we trust each other.
- Beth!
- That's how we do it, but yeah...
- Sheez, Beth, I'm just like,
(laughing)
"It's a whole ep...
Just a whole show in itself."
I'm just like, "There's a lot in there."
(laughing)
Yeah, that character.
I'm just like, "What are
these writers doing?"
- Oh, yeah.
- Oh, man.
Anyway, it's so good though.
So, were either of you
comfortable on horses
or were you those actors that totally lied
and said, "I can ride
a horse" and couldn't?
- I think it was on my resume
that I could ride a horse,
but I was totally lying.
- No, but that doesn't mean
it's real. Okay.
- No, I was terrified.
(laughing)
Not at all.
- Yeah.
- I was terrible.
- You look like you can ride a horse.
- I can a little bit, now.
You know, we've been working
- Yeah.
on it for 5 years at this point.
- You know,
they've had us doing a lot of, you know,
working with some really good people,
doing some cowboy camps,
that sort of thing.
- Yeah.
- So, yeah a little better now.
- Wait is cowboy camp,
like "City slickers?"
I imagine that's what it is.
Like, you know-
- Yeah.
- Pretty much.
- But with actors.
Like really annoying actors.
- That's insane.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, they were like,
we went on this cowboy camp
that we had these like, Paul Bunyan type,
real cowboys who do pack rides.
- Yeah.
- And like we wanted,
we were to go out in the, off the grid,
and live with them and try to survive.
And learn how to ride horses and stuff.
- Yeah.
- But it was an adventure though.
- Wait, that sounds fun!
- It was crazy though.
We kinda got separated from
those Paul Bunyan types
and it was just actors alone
in the woods for a minute.
(laughing)
For a minute.
- How do you get, how
does one get separated?
Were they just playing a prank on you
and they leave you? Like what?
- We were wondering if it was
like part of the thing,
- Yeah.
- like, "They're doing this on purpose.
They'll be here any minute."
- Yeah.
No, too late.
- No, we didn't see 'em
'til the next day.
We were just-
- And you're in Montana?
- Utah at that moment.
- Yeah.
- Oh, I was like,
- Yeah, yeah.
"Were there bears and wolves?"
- Yeah.
Were there bears there too?
I'm like, "On my property alone
all of that exists."
- We thought-
We thought we saw a bear
in the distance. You remember that?
We were like, "There's
some figure way off"
and we couldn't figure
out what exactly it was.
- Yeah, I think it was one of the cowboys
keeping an eye on us.
(laughing)
(indistinct)
- Just messing with you,
- Yeah.
- dressed up
as Smokey the bear.
- Just making sure
we didn't die.
(laughing)
- Did you ever ride horses before,
or did you...
- I did the same thing.
I put it on my resume and I actually,
I got really close to a job, "Beloved,"
this movie by Jonathan Demme
and they put me on a
train out to Philadelphia
from New York to meet
him to get this role.
Small role,
- Yeah.
but it is important to me.
And I went and met with him
and we walked the hallway
and he was sort of like,
"Can you do an accent?"
I'm like, "Yeah, I can do accents."
He says, "Can you ride a horse?"
I said, "Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
I wrote it on my resume,
- Total!
- right? Yeah."
- I can also lie.
- Then he said,
"Well you need to go over there."
Yeah. (laughing)
- Do you need me to do that?
- Yeah.
- He said, "Why don't you go over there
to the wranglers and ride some horses
and they'll see where you're at."
And I just panicked
- Oh.
- and I got on and as soon as I got on,
they I was lying.
(all laughing)
I got the role.
- He did.
(laughing)
- Yeah.
- There you go.
- Lying works.
- They were like, "He's bold, check."
- Yeah.
- He's like, "He'll do anything."
- I guess so.
- That is frightening,
That you just,
- It is frightening.
- they're like, "Hop on a horse and go."
- (indistinct) horses, yeah.
- Yeah.
- Soon as you touch 'em,
they're like, "Dang,"
they took off, yeah.
- Yeah, they sense fear.
Don't be fearful.
Are your kids into the show?
- Oh yeah, I mean, they
don't watch it, but-
- They know a bi-atch.
(all laughing)
Just Beth alone.
- Yeah, yeah.
They do know there's some bad things
that are right to do.
One's not watch Yellowstone yet,
but no, they wanted to ride horses
at first and they did.
And then we went back and forth.
But what my son was really up to
in the first couple seasons was
he was trying to land Luke Grimes.
Attached to his little script he wrote,
remember?
- Oh, yeah.
- The character's name.
- What was mine?
- Jake Microsoft.
(all laughing)
- My son was 6 or 7, yeah.
- I gotta stop laughing.
- He spent a lot of energy
- I forgot about.
- trying to bug Luke.
(laughing)
Not me.
- Not you.
(laughing)
He wanted a real...
Isn't that amazing how humbling it is?
Your kids?
- Oh, he didn't care for whatever I did.
- Oh no, literally, like my kids said
they didn't care at all.
And literally, I came home
and like Ariana Grande
was on "The Voice" with me
and they were like, "Who?"
And I was like, "What?"
- Yeah, oh yeah.
- I was like, "They
don't care what you do."
- No.